je voulais jamais raconter cette
histoire mais je vais le raconter ce
soir il m'est arrivé un truc de ouf dans
un club allez-y il ya très très
longtemps car ça commence comme ça
je vous lis ça commence comme ça il ya
très très longtemps
je vais dans un club aux marques entre
vacanciers ou non tu vas consignes à
quand je suis là bas comme si je suis
pas connu un si bel âge à peu près à peu
près aussi je suis pas connu je sais pas
quand même temps et à très vite qu'ils
étaient très longtemps à dire ne suis
pas connu 40 ans déjà non mais je ne
suis pas connu je ne suis pas connu et
donc les gens ne savent pas qui chouine
est très large et j'arrive dans un club
et je suis avec une meuf gvt est un
conseil qu'une en coûte trois jours avec
une meuf aux
jv tout se passe bien et un moment on
est dans le monde et à la piscine et je
vois une meuf
c'était l'âge et aux danses orientales
et là je vous dis curieuse méthode
donc là je sais pas ce qui me prend
je la connais pas mais je voulais la
masse et la calandre je crains de deux
bronzes et tranquille et je me lève
comme un ouf et je vais dans sec
l'annoncions
ème siècle dans la piscine et l'on jette
dans la piscine
dans la piscine et vanessa rigolant
comment tu t'appelles j'adore mon
caleçon
histoire de trois noms de chanteurs
orientaux que je connais farida
l'autruche tutti quanti
surtout un khaled rachita faudel
tellement je t'aime je pense à toi tout
humain et il y avait deux clubs là la
côte et d'autre et je l'unité dont
quelques pas de me dire je suis dans le
club jeudi après tout elle dit wendy
bagdad ayant joué dans le club je suis à
faire comme dans l'homme qui m'a élevé
donc je vais faire une autre un autre
cours de danse orientale c'est peut-être
mieux que je me perfectionne tu penses
toi
donc je vais dans l'autre club et âme ma
meuf et tout temps comme dans les allées
ont fracassé
et la dangeureuse
chien je vais faire une p ton car
il ya un gros tournant donc là bas côté
je vais y aller parce que ils ont besoin
d'un joueur et tu sais que c'est ma
passion quoi bon ben hamadi ben dis donc
là je prends le bus avec la danseuse
orientale on peut prendre un bus pour
élever mes trois buts cette compagnie
dont le but chauffeur
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]
guérir
au verso recommande au maracanã
là
je vois la moto ça on est bien et là on
arrive au club
et là comme par hasard elle me dit mon
cours est annulé
et là je dis c'est un coup dur pour la
danse orientale
[Rires]
il a bon dos fil en aiguille une chose
en entraînant et nous on se retrouve
dans sa case
parce qu'elle avait un truc à aller
chercher way plus tôt que prévu qu on la
combat là voilà donc ça ça se paie cash
ou un peu non sachez bon si cinq ans
avec votre 9 à quoi tu sais quoi
ouais j'ai vu 80 ou 100 m c'est quoi ces
mots-là ces accusations la caisse qui
fait plaisir c'est que heureusement vous
avez changé senna et amélie pas filmer
non qu'est ce que je fais l'histoire
n'est pas finie ah ça c'est tout le bon
et alors tu es le décor est ce que je
fais je reviens au club et là je suis
resté longtemps là-bas je restais au
moins trois heures pour le concours de
pets de grosses grosses bêtes en gros
c'est là je reviens je suis parti à 14h
il est 19 heures
qu'est ce que je fais je vais l'accueil
qui donnez moi une raquette de tennis je
prends une raquette de 10 et je vais
direct au tennis et là j'arrive au
tennis et je vois ma meuf arriver mais
de très loin
et là attendez mais c'est pas là une
histoire elle est incroyable là je suis
avec les autres choquant à gori tout ça
est un moment il ya une géo vente et
taquin de payet sur le corps
et je suis dit mais
il ya un autre joyau qui arrive c'est
que t'as plein de pahlen et l'ail en
acharif et la super league
et là
qu'arrive l'autre qui dit ça la joie une
piscine jean claude plessis
sur brabham a failli en train de faire
des bras cela j'ai vraiment besoin de me
détendre j'ai perdu le tournoi de
pétanque show au bout de ma vie là les
mecs non mais une histoire mais vraiment
histoire vers vraiment histoire vraie
incroyable et là ils avaient si votre
retour moi je serai remis les wemade
article mais vous que j'ai revu la jla
mais non non oui mais votre métabolisme
parti c'est fini se mettre à douter de
rien pendant la semaine de vacances sans
rien du tout alors ces patients étaient
en trois jours c'est bon c'est bon non
mais alors en une semaine nous en
attraper combien
[Rires]
pas du tout la médaille a crush et un
coup de foudre se marie au kosovo tu as
très bien sûr j'étais jeune et un chien
fou ouvert de paillettes même sur loeb
[Applaudissements]
mais franchement les ressaisies cd
vite que vous ne croyez donc je ne dis
pas non mais c'est vrai la raison
benhaim ah oui vous comprenez bien sûr
vous étiez un chien fou au lâcher comme
ça dans un chien tout va
comme ça c'était comment la commune
active epa la map à la marelle en
battant alla bras d'honneur aux et
[Musique]
oui oui tout ça maintenant ça est
vraiment pas ce que vous referiez la
même chose
je le dis franchement cd voiçi changé
[Rires]
oui j'ai changé ah oui j'échange indom
chabot non mais c'est oui j'ai changé
j'ai changé de nom mais ça y est
maintenant ma tête et je suis sérieux
voilà la fois sur fois que tu vois là
quand je serai sérieux
dit la vérité je suis debout qui me
connaît franchement non non je vais
d'ailleurs pour de vrai je suis viré
prospérité la nana la vérité et la
vérité vont s'y arrête c'est vrai c'est
l'homme qui a changé non c'est non non
c'est vrai qu'il savait qu'il a changé
non c'est maintenant
que tu me le dis il a changé gafi fait
tapis de paye
il te frapper
ses lunettes forteresse érigée
sur la torah
[Applaudissements]
alors je vous dis je refuse et je le dis
bien je refuse que tu jures sur la torah
à une heure de chabal
là je refuse mais là je te le dis je
refais raison c'est pas bien voilà ça
c'est hors de question mais on revoit
des règles claires
non mais j'ai eu dix ans des nouvelles
règles assure-t-on excuse moi toi tu
voir une nouvelle réclame la nouvelle
actu à la terre chez toi ça te faire
tourner toi car tu va relancer des
vidéos de chaque équipe est d'environ
[Applaudissements]
d'avoir l'idée des chèques tu as un
match tony jaa thuram a répondu non mais
c'est moi ont pu intégrer menace si vous
êtes un saint non mais franchement
vous êtes monde sait qu'on va le faire
parce que la
saisie d'un coup ça
pour la rosette syrie oui un mec bien
exact mais c'est vrai que c'est vrai
et je n'ai aucun problème avec ça on est
vraiment ça y est je te le dit shawn
assez fidèle à sa carrière moi a donné
dernièrement [ __ ] vous avez tous et
isa tendres attaques de dab en boîtier
tribu sérieux considère non mais
tillabéri très sérieux chez les vrais
aux plus riches et à rester encore
quelques jours mais noté un sérieux
je me tourne vers celui qui est le plus
proche de moi avec qui j'ai passé de
nombreuses soirées vous êtes sérieux et
les femmes être demandeuses non mais
n'ont été arrêtés les batailles auprès
de combien de femmes
fiona je suis pas triste
non non la b non mais vraiment un quart
matthieu delormeau voulait rentrer
excusez moi
je dois demander maintenant vous dire
quelque chose dans la tête si la
brouille et dites moi
mais ça rigolait
elle vient tous à la salle
non mais très haut je n'avais plus de
vacances mais qu est-ce qu avec cette
madame 100 sur nos vies nous
connaissez c'est un truc ah ouais quand
même et quelle à des tâches à une banane
dalmatiens
on hésite à la manger le fait est que ça
d'ailleurs il est malade encore
non pourquoi je vous dis ça parce que ce
matin je donne tu es texto j'étais en
taxi way et je mets bébé c'est
inadmissible c'est inadmissible sur un
quart d'heure de retard et mais n'y a
aucun problème mon coeur on t'attend
franchement non mais j'ai bossé dix ans
dans la finance peuvent dire que j'avais
pas les réponses comme ça quand j'étais
en retard non auprès de mon patron ça me
touche web pardon à tous merci au revoir
à l'entrée
[Applaudissements]
tu tombe bien
mettons très bien est ce que pour toi je
suis un homme sérieux et les femmes dit
la vérité
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]
mais sa vie avec cette course hors des
séries avec les pas dit la vérité quand
tu les très très très bien voilà c'est
toujours vu ça les
saints comment si tu l'as tu l'as très
très très bien toujours tu peux te sens
tu la mets en avant tu es généreux
qu'est ce qu'elle veut faire qu'est ce
qu'elle aime son bonheur c'est le tien
là je suis célibataire
et si oui bah c'est spéciaux ims cède
son bonheur c'était le tiens voilà est
la même je sais même que tu es
célibataire pour le bien de l'autre ce
n'est pas
j'aurais dû venir un type au plus tard